we're not physically queuing up you show
up you clock in when you need to go home
you need to go to work you clock out
there are rules for the day and there
are rules at night the rules are don't
lose your job don't get a divorce no
blasters uh-huh you know that's about it
during the day it's pretty calm we
talked about Star Wars and well we
talked about Leia costume at night all
the crazies come out
how many times have I seen the Star Wars
films it's impossible to count that
100-plus pretty easy it I was like my
going to bed movie for years I think the
original trilogy probably 50 to 100
times I can no longer count I can recite
the dialogue by hearing the piece of
music the original 1977 Star Wars in a
theater almost 400 times the prequels
probably ate two or three times per
movie it's all about the original
trilogy for me I was 10 years old when
it came out I saw it here second day it
was open and changed my life I mean I
still dressed like a Jedi 40 years later
that's got to say something
I started lining up in episode 2 line I
made a lot of really great friends that
I'm still friends with the first day
that I showed up to the 99 line it was
the feeling that I had come home for the
first time ever it's actually just like
a family reunion people tend to have a
lot of joy no one's really judging me
about all the things that normal people
might say oh that's weird that you
really like to dress up as a Sith Lord
or that's really strange that you know
all these little intricate details about
starships that don't exist 90% of us are
friends even outside of line I showed up
at this line not knowing anybody and now
I have all these great friends
I'm so sad when these lines are over
when this has gone over I've never felt
like I belonged anywhere else